welcome to this via playing freedom at
sera from Brazil and it's a French game
yeah perfect be fun now let's let's play
that oh cool chicks this is um this is a
ram why is it ramped don't know Quincy
for maybe yeah how do you protect it now
g6 it's very ugly so maybe you can make
a sacrifice out of it with 97 this is a
possibility Knight f6 I can take ok this
one or just here then No yeah I like to
break the pin yeah I like to break the
pain
yeah maybe you should consider a uniform
getting them the Queen's off but doesn't
look like it's concerning it I know is
playing it okay need to need to take and
yeah I don't really want him to spoil a
construction though it is a very lame
booth I'm aware of that yeah b6 Bishop
beside me this is probably home so I I
made some kind of some kind of mistake
allowing him this equal position 96 at
least some kind of a threat the night is
is a bit a bit misplaced down I can try
to get a pawn on d5 and 926 he's
actually encouraging that this is
surprising the knight on c6 is not doing
that much but it's a it's still annoying
check
ok he wants to play em yeah I see just
98 am ok then this was project
completely ok for blood
check
that's just an hien equal end game
check
I have a slight slight space advantage
but it's nothing to to really put any
hopes on and I forgot to play whoopsie 6
mmm this was bad
hmm yeah this was bad now he's actually
able to play King be five
and nonsense why did I know that yeah I
was too relaxed here this position
simply I don't don't get get anything
here why doesn't he play rupee form of
course I can take c7 but he can get both
pawns now he just has a weakness on f6 I
ok he can't play rook h8 but I can just
protect it no one have a potential yeah
okay
yeah it's probably prob'ly draw at the
end check
check
yeah I hope it's still a draw not not
sure
yeah this I believe is a draw check
check check check all right here you're
never going to win dead
yeah maybe on time check check check
check check check check yeah this is
just a draw check check stalemate yeah
mm-hmm okay it probably was also draw
all along I mean not he had winning
winning chances of course but I mean
before I I allowed the King activation
which was really idiotic here this move
I need to of course first player 36 but
then he kept a rupee one whom so yeah so
maybe I assess this all wrong but I
thought you would play just just took a
look II for him check ya wanted to play
actively maybe this should have lost
check look H for no yeah ambassador I
must be I must be losing it look aged
Freud's good
and we can move the drip on my king is
on 83 yeah I was very lucky to to save
the game probably check check check yeah
how do I am what was my mistake here
that I got into trouble a form a forest
bed of course and I need to play f3 yeah
this is this is this is check
instructive even for weekends this
square so that after this I have a
problem if I just player 3 then it's
alright i'm covering this with the king
and even if he goes to d5 there's no
threat of any penetration so i can i can
just shuffle and I'm okay yeah this is
the problem f4 was bad at least after 4i
need to be cautious and here it's just
just nothing alright thanks for watching